من القاهره تنضم الي عبر الطفل المتحدثه
الاعلاميه ومديره الوحده الاقليميه
للاعلام في برنامج الغذاء العالميه سيد
عبيد اهلا بك معنا وصف الوضع في السودان
وبرنامج الغذاء العالمي قال بان هذا الوضع
كارثي هل يمكن ان تعطينا صوره واضحه على
ما يجري في السودان
طبعا ميسون الوضع صعب في داخل السودان
كان ثلث سكان السودان يعانون من اعدام
الامن الغذائي هذا حوالي 15 مليون شخص
البرنامج كان يقدم مساعدات غذائيه بصوره
شهريه الى ما يزيد على السبعه ونصف
المليون شخص بصوره شهريه طبعا
الانباء الاخيره يعني وما حصلنا عليه من
معلومات هناك طبعا مشكله كبيره في سلسله
الامداد والتموين للمواد الغذائيه في كثير
من المناطق في السودان بالاضافه ايضا الى
ارتفاع
اسعار المواد الغذائيه بسبب
تواجد يعني وجود هذه المواد في المحال
والمتاجر وبالتالي كل هذه الاوضاع يعني
تنبئ عن وضع انساني كارثي وعلى الاشخاص في
في في يعني وضعيه الامن الغذائي لان
المجتمعات هناك بالفعل هشه جدا وعلى الاخص
في المناطق خارج الخرطوم والمناطق في يعني
في المحافظات التي كان بها صراعات لفتره
طويله مثل شمال دارفور وبالتالي احنا
نتوقع طبعا اكيد اذا استمرت الاوضاع بهذه
يعني الطريقه سيكون هناك عواقب وخيمه على
الوضع الامني الغذائي هناك اربعه ملايين
طفل في السودان بيعانوا من سوء التغذيه
بالاضافه ايضا الى عدد كبير من عمليه سوء
التغذيه ما بين الامهات هذا قبل الاحداث
بعد هذه الاحداث ونحن يعني نعلم هل هناك
خطه الطوارئ الان للتعامل مع ما يجري الان
على ارض السودان من قبل برنامج الغذاء
العالمي خاصه بقدر الاوضاع الامنيه يعني
ليست جيده ابدا الاحتياجات وتحديد كيفيه
العمل في السودان على في الايام المقبله
طبعا البرنامج كان علق
عمله داخل السودان بسبب يعني سوء وتردي
الاوضاع الامنيه كان هناك مقتل لثلاثه من
موظفي البرنامج بالاضافه ايضا الى تحطم
لطائره في مطار الخرطوم
عمليه سرقه ونهب
لمخازن ومستودعات البرنامج في كثير من
المناطق وسرقه اكثر من 10 سيارات كل هذه
الظروف لماذا اذكرها لانها يعني هي يعني
تعطيك صوره عن صعوبه التحرك والعمل في
داخل السودان في هذا الوقت وبالتالي
طالب طبعا بهدنه بوقف اطلاق النار وفي نفس
الوقت هناك خطه كيفيه التعامل مع السودان
خلال الظروف الجديده التي تشهدها البلاد
وايضا التركيز على تقديم المساعدات
والمعونه
اللاجئين الذين صروا الى دول الجوار او
الذين نزحوا داخلين الى مناطق اكثر
امنا من مناطق هل اصبح لديكم احصائيات عن
عدد النازحين او اللاجئين الذين خرجوا من
السودان امباعد سيدي عبير
ما زالت الصوره غير متضحه
بالنسبه للعدد الاعداد لكن يعني على الاقل
من ناحيه الحدود المصريه هناك عشرات
الالاف خرجوا ودخلوا الى الحدود المصريه
بالاضافه ايضا الى الكثير الذين نزحوا
ودخلوا الى حدود شاب لكن في الوقت الحالي
بيتم حصر والتعامل مع دول الجوار من قبل
مصادر عليا لشؤون اللاجئين حتى يكون هناك
حصر الاعداد اللاجئين وايضا التعامل مع
كيفيه ما هي الاحتياجات اذا كان هؤلاء
سيكونوا موجودين في هذه المناطق ام
وبالتالي عمليه تقديمه مساعدات نقديه او
غذائيه او ما الى خلاف ذلك
السيده عبير بالنسبه ايضا
لموضوع اللاجئين الذين يعني خاصه الاكثريه
هي ذهبت الى مصر سيتم التعامل مع برنامج
الغذاء العالمي مكتب مصر مع هؤلاء
اللاجئين
بالفعل طبعا هناك بالفعل اليوم يعني في
ربما على مدار اليومين الماضيين كان هناك
فريق من عمل برنامج الاغذيه العالمي من
مكتب مصر موجودين في المناطق الحدوديه
لتقييم الاحتياجات والتعامل مع الهلال
الاحمر المصري والحكومه المصريه حتى يكون
هناك تقديم سريع للمساعدات الغذائيه واذا
كان هناك سيكون يعني هناك وجود لهؤلاء
لفتره اطول سيكون هناك طبعا
تفكير في تقديم المساعدات النقديه كل هذه
السيناريوهات والخطط يعني بيتم وضعها الان
حتى يكون هناك في الساعات المقبله
يعني عمليه
اطلاق مساعدات لهؤلاء بصوره عاجله طب هل
يتم الاتصال
بقاده الاطراف المتنازعه من اجل تامين
ممرات امنه لبرنامج الغذاء العالمي
وللمنظمات الدوليه اقله يعني لمساعده
الناس الذين اصبحت اوضاعهم سيئه جدا خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين
طبعا هناك اتصالات ما بين الامين العام
للامم المتحده السيد انطونيو جوتارس
والقيادات في داخل السودان لاننا كلنا
نعمل تحت مظله الامم المتحده والاحتياجات
ليست فقط غذائيه ولكن هناك ايضا صحيه
واحتياجات يعني على على كل المستويات
والبرنامج يعني طبعا ليس لا اعتقد ان هناك
خطوط اتصال مفتوحه مع القيادات الا عن
طريق السيد انطونيو جيتارس الامين العام
ولكن طبعا نحن يعني في منتهى القلق لان
كما هو في كل حالات الطوارئ غالبا الذين
يذهبون الى المناطق الحدوديه هم من لديهم
الاموال التي تمكنهم من السفر والوصول الى
هذه المناطق ولكن دائما ما يبقى اكثر يعني
ضعفا والاكثر فقرا والاكثر احتياجا هم من
يعني
ينتهي بهم الامر في داخل مناطق الصراع
وبالتالي عمليه فتح الممرات الامنه
والهدنه
ووقف اطلاق النار حتى لو كان لساعات هو
اهم شيء يعني بنطلبه في هذه المرحله حتى
نستطيع انقاذ ارواح هؤلاء شكرا لك من
القاهره عبير عطيفه المتحدثه الاعلاميه
ومديره الوحده الاقليميه للاعلام في
برنامج الغذاء العالمي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات